this mex always going to be available
knowledge alert to those who own the
expansion pass and envy you widely Oh
what existing operators
you
operator
a skater
you can actually pick up an entire tower
from what I've seen like that
it lack of a control station request our
seats
so I guess a lot good deal i support
cars in this game and yes I businesses
bombs on wheels this is upgraded back
right I think so was the occasional
anything no this is different than when
you were playing earlier right right so
oh yeah it's kind of different way
around so the other ones out kind of
like a gattling can you show the front
of them not really I believe this is the
mecca you guys are seeing on the top
right there in the corner which is our
here
I'm sorry getting hang this
visit just
we're going to try to liberate this area
with Justin
p throw at our one of those guys or try
to check something at them and I'm going
to do
it's something so you liberated that the
detention camp pony more B's all I Do's
parachute disappeared he fell to his
death to see that
valerian
can you launch the Bavarian on
at
and just go far go away for her an enemy
to be a little closer ever gone what if
you hug it did you pick him up as well
yeah
we're gonna bring this around it oh no
get back in no oh good all right we're
going to skydive with a comeback okay
see if I can aim towards that Island
over can even you want you getting
maneuver it up just travel and money
lands i'll select a winner oh I think
it's a nice happening right survive
don't survive that
welcome back I go off you guys
Wow caught some hair they're like I have
maniacally Rico's a sick man
so once we show this little motorcycle
stunt I will select the winner of the
land she's taking off she does not like
what's about to happen
amazing she's fighting it really well
usually he's doing like raising Donuts
so without further ado um I guess we
will sign off thanks guys oh and thanks
for any alias for being the man at the
helm of Rico and causing obstruction and
showing us was two tips and tricks for
winning the winning on contest see you
soon
you